Look at this.
These are people who claim to respect
Jesus.
They claim to honor Jesus.
They claim to follow
Jesus.
But they pay absolutely no attention to
anything he said.
What would Jesus say
about Muslims gathering in Times Square
to get maximum attention for their
prayers
while they pretend to fast during
Ramadan?
We don't have to wonder. All we have to
do is read, read, read, read, read.
In Matthew 6, Jesus condemns
religious practices
that are meant to impress other people.
Acts of righteousness
that are just for show.
The chapter begins.
Beware of practicing your righteousness
before other people in order to be seen
by them.
For then you will have no reward from
your father who is in heaven.
If your goal when you pray or fast or
give to charity
is to be seen by others
then being seen by others is your
reward.
You get no reward from God.
Verses 5 to 6.
And when you pray
you must not be like the hypocrites.
For they love to stand and pray in the
synagogues and at the street corners
that they may be seen by others.
Truly I say to you, they have received
their reward.
BUT WHEN YOU PRAY, go into your room and
shut the door and pray to your father
who is in secret. And your father, who
sees in secret,
will reward you.
If you're praying to put on a show,
if you're praying to be seen by others,
like all of these people,
then being seen by others is your
reward. No reward from God.
But, Jesus isn't done. Verses 16 to 18.
And when you fast, do not look gloomy
like the hypocrites, for they disfigure
their faces,
that their fasting may be seen by
others.
Truly, I say to you, they have received
their reward.
But, when you fast, anoint your head and
wash your face,
that your fasting may not be seen by
others, but by your father, who is in
secret.
And your father, who sees in secret,
will reward you.
>> [music]
>> Jesus condemns prayer that's meant to be
seen by others. He condemns fasting
that's meant to be seen by others.
If you're praying and fasting
in order to gain a reputation for
righteousness,
Jesus says that your prayer and fasting
are worthless before God.
But, it gets worse.
Because when Jesus condemns fasting
that's meant to be seen by others,
he's talking about people who are really
fasting. He's talking about people who
are
really fasting, but they want everyone
to notice.
Imagine what Jesus would think
of this public fasting
if the people doing it aren't really
fasting.
Imagine the level of contempt Jesus
would have for a religious practice of
public fasting that isn't even fasting.
Ramadan is a month of feasting
that for some reason is called fasting.
It's trans fasting. It's feasting that
identifies as fasting.
Muslims gorge themselves with food at
night.
Then gorge themselves with food early in
the morning.
Then sleep all day.
They wake up in the evening and gorge
themselves with food again.
Then they gorge themselves again in the
early morning.
And again sleep all day.
They call this month-long cycle of binge
eating and sleeping fasting.
No one else in the history of the world
thinks you're fasting when you're
feasting.
But this is Islam. So, remember that the
rules of opposite world are in full
effect.
The Muslim population spends a month out
of every year
binge eating while pretending that binge
eating is fasting.
And here we have Muslims gathering in
Times Square
to make sure the entire world knows
they're praying and pretending to fast.
Jesus condemns doing acts of
righteousness to be seen by others. He
calls people who do acts of
righteousness for show
hypocrites.
Everything in Islam is for show.
Look at me, I'm praying. Look at me, I'm
fasting. Look at me, I'm giving Dawah.
Check out my zabiba.
I think it's safe to say that when an
entire religion encourages doing acts of
righteousness to be seen by others
Jesus would call a religion of
hypocrisy.
Happy Ramadan to all the Muslims who are
watching this in the middle of the night
because you sleep all day.
You claim to respect Jesus
when all you do is the exact opposite of
everything he said.
If you have a drop of genuine respect
for Jesus,
then remember
what Jesus said about your hypocritical
version of make-believe fasting
as you're gorging yourselves with food
early in the morning and preparing for a
difficult day of sleeping.
If you do take
everything
Jesus said
about what not to do as part of your
religion
and you roll it all up into a ball,
you get Islam.
Islam is an antichrist religion. It's
antichrist nonsense.
Leave this pagan hypocrisy.
Leave the fake Isa of Islam
and follow the true Lord,
Jesus Christ.
It is back fighting me.
>> [music]
>> It is back fighting me. This is a
powerful religion. There's a reason to
it. Yeah? Yeah? Yeah?